[Music]
[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
yes we open this up and we challenge
viewers try and find a mistake so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
we don't make mistakes tonight a fan
named Tom Knowles thinks he's caught a
mistake he says it happened when I was
interviewing recently my guest Jason
Schwartzman
what's up Conan my name is Tom and I
definitely found an error in tonight's
episode didn't in your interview with
Jason Schwartzman let's take a look what
guy in the audience named Trevor and I
are gonna get a plane and we're gonna go
on some crazy adventure well I will go
with you as long as my web says we're
gonna bring protein shakes and a lot of
Emily Dickinson you may have a tough
time bringing Emily Dickens bones and
your great adventure coz Emily Dickens
wasn't a poet Emily Dickinson was let's
see a string dancer way out of this one
Coco
I thought was nice of Tom to make a
video while he was contemplating suicide
in a stairwell look where it's
ridiculous
I'm gonna end it all right now but first
a fan correction for Coco who are you
talking to in the basement rugs all
right where I want him
well I'm sorry
Tom but you're dead wrong I wasn't
talking about Emily Dickinson I was
talking about contemporary American poet
Emily Dickens in fact miss Dickens was
in the national spotlight
just last night take a look and if you
want to know the real impact the arts
are having just listen to the great
American poet Emily dick who's here
tonight mrs. Dickens would you honor us
with a poem roses are red
we all wish you luck except for the guy
from the dynasty of duck
[Applause]
I may be wrong but I now count 65
applause breaks so far I think we're
gonna get another fan correction about
that so anyway the challenge still
stands if you think you've spotted an
error on our show reported at Team
koco.com slash haha I found an error we
will sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you have what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the maestro
very nice